what is your favorite or the most
beautiful chemical reaction one of my
favorites is a very simple reaction but
it excites me every time
it's simple combustion of hydrogen I
really like that and it's a very simple
reaction but I just like the speed and
the noise it makes
I also like the barking dog' which some
of you may have seen because I do the
backing dog sometimes but really half of
the barking dog' but I really like
hydrogen combustion you've really put me
on the spot with that one because
there's so many we need to add only one
mil so that's one centimeter cubed of
the copper sulfate deep blue color and
again we'll have to give this one a
helping hand and I only expect it to be
quite so Wow not just the individual
crystals but what they're next to as
well they're all lovely they're all my
babies so you know you can't pick a
favorite child as it were I love
wrestling around with dry ice despite
the incident with the cannon balls I
probably yeah being able to just bucket
chemistry throw in handfuls of dry ice
into a huge tub of soapy water
watching all froth up watching the
audience reaction for me the most
important thing whether it's doing a
scientific experiment or gift-giving is
watching that person's reaction I don't
know think about it oh goodness
let me think well I want possibly my
most favorite reaction is an extremely
dangerous reaction to make a particular
phosphorous compound and you have to
react white phosphorus which comes
stored into water because it burns in
air otherwise with a mixture of sodium
and potassium which is a molten alloy
and that reacts explosively with water
so you have to make sure you've got rid
of all the water from the white
phosphorus before you let it see the
sodium potassium
and it makes this horrible black gunge
and then you put another reagent in to
get the product that you're actually
after and it's unbelievably dangerous as
a reaction but it's great when you get
the product out the other end and you're
still alive
there's so many chemical reactions which
are which are really fantastic and often
nature develops things which you just
would not but ever of dreamt of is a is
a chemist
there are various reactions you can do
with vanadium okay so vanadium is
transition metal top row of the
transition Wells and it has various
oxidation states and you can actually
the undergraduates do that he do this
here actually but they do it with
titrations which I don't think they find
so fun but you can cycle through all
these various oxidation states in
vanadium and basically go from things
the yellow things that are lilac e
purple things agreeing to things that
are blue so that's quite beautiful cuz
it's a lot of nice very pretty colors so
a molecule called caliche Meissen and
it's got a trisulfide a3 sulfur's in a
row as it is a trigger for this molecule
and it turns out that this molecule
which is found in a rock like why does a
rock need a chemical defense mechanism
bacteria live inside of rock crazy but
this is such a warhead and actually now
it's it's part of an anti-cancer type
drug I like the Wittig reaction that's
the reaction which makes two carbons
come together but to make a PI bond so
you get two bonds and forming in one two
carbon carbon bonds forming one it's
very useful for making natural products
with PI bonds I think that's my favorite
reaction you've got a very strained
alkyne alkyne system you've got a
trisulfide so three sulfur's in a row
this comes down opens a bridge it brings
the alkynes slightly together and then
these alkynes undergo what's called a
Bergeron cyclisation which forms a die
radical so this is pretty complex you
know it's this is James Bond's worst
enemies
most crazy planet killing him right it's
just nuts and you get a
a benzene ring a bit like this one with
a radical either and that radical can
then attack the DNA and destroy so it is
just such an extraordinary thing you
would never ever of in your wildest
dreams come up with this sort of plan
and you would never predict it would
work but it does work it's been found in
a rock well when I was a PhD student I
made a series of chiral carboxylic acids
so these are molecules which are a bit
like your hand you have a form that
looks like the left hand and a form that
looks like the right hand and when I
made these molecules they were all
jumbled up in what we call a racemic
mixture and it was really important to
separate these two enantiomers of these
chiral molecules so there's a very very
simple reaction which is you take an
acid in a base and you make a salt plus
a water so I took this chiral carboxylic
acids and I reacted it with a chiral
amine to make a chiral salt so when you
pour these components together into a
great big bath of water and stir them up
you get this unusual sort of cloudiness
that appears in the reaction and then
almost instantly you get wonderful
crystal growth and you see tiny little
crystals which then balloon up in these
rather large circular structures sfera
lights and these sort of pom-poms of
molecules are just floating in the water
and it was just in chanting just to
watch it and I and I often sat for like
40 minutes just watching this
crystallization and that was just a
fantastic process yeah it's quite
surprising for me because everyone
associates me with energetic reactions
and you know this was really quite low
in energy and really gentle and really
quite serene many chemical reactions can
be very beautiful especially those with
color changes one of my favorite
reactions is the reaction of hydrogen
peroxide with potassium permanganate
potassium permanganate is purple and if
you add hydrogen
Rockside he goes colorless and I've
always been really fascinated by that
reaction since I was quite young I
suppose recently with the videos one of
my favorite chemical reactions has to be
the barking dog you know in the big
glass tube because that really is a
dramatic experiment than this it takes a
lot of preparation and it's over in a
split-second then it's just oh it's just
amazing and it takes your breath away
every time
[Music]